[Music]
this will be an overview of web
components and how they've quietly
started powering more of the web than
you may be aware first we'll take a look
at the current state of web components
adoption in the real world and then
we'll dive into the use cases that are
actually driving that real world
adoption including a guest spot from our
friends at Salesforce and finally I'll
give an overview of how you can get
started solving some of these same use
cases today with web components
all right so how many people out there
are actually using web components today
so that's sort of a trick question
because everyone is actually using web
components whether you know it or not
because as a user of the web every one
of you probably use them on a daily
basis
that's because web components are
statistically speaking one of the most
successful new browser features shipped
in recent history by our count over five
percent of page loads today use a web
component in one way or another putting
it in the top handful of major new web
platform features shipped in the last
five years web components can be found
on big properties you probably visit on
a daily basis like YouTube and github
web components are prolific across news
and publishing sites built on amp since
amp is built on web components and
finally enterprises are finding huge
success with web components which we'll
explore more in a moment but first what
are web components in modern web
development today pretty much everyone
uses components to encapsulate UI
functionality web components allow us to
extend the browser with new components
like an image carousel that can be
expressed as normal HTML as if they were
part of the platform web components are
low-level browser api's that give us a
standard interface for defining new
components web components have a common
way of being created using HTML and
standard Dom API is that every framework
uses and a common way of receiving and
sending data using properties and events
but outside of that standard interface
web components don't say anything about
how the component is actually
implemented or how to build apps out of
them so web components are not one
specific framework for building apps and
they don't set out to replace frameworks
they don't tell us how to render or
update the guts of a component they're
really not opinionated at all web
components simply tell the browser when
and where to create a component but not
how authors can choose functional
rendering patterns just like you might
and react to build web components or
they can use declarative templates like
you might find an angular or view for
example as an author we have total
freedom to choose a stack within the
component or use no stack at all while
still maintaining interoperability and
this is the key difference between web
components and proprietary component
libraries because of their standard
interface web components can work
anywhere a built-in element like input
or video can so we can make a custom tab
bar component for example and use that
in markup on an HTML page but also in
all the popular frameworks like react or
angular because web components can be
expressed as real HTML and rendered by
frameworks using standard Dom api's all
of this means that once you've made an
investment in creating components they
can be consumed more widely in a more
diverse range of applications because
they work with virtually any framework
anywhere the web works and so users of
our components aren't locked into any
one framework so that future proofs us
from painful migrations when we
inevitably need to update our stack
since web components are portable across
frameworks so for all of these reasons
web components are actually finding huge
success in a variety of different use
cases so let's take a look at those web
components are the perfect technology
for progressively enhancing HTML content
because they can already be output as
standard HTML by an untold number of CMS
systems already out there an amp is a
great example of how quickly an easily
web components slotted into the
publishing industry's infrastructure for
serving content because amp components
are simply expressed as HTML another
obviously great fit for web components
is in creating design systems how many
of you work with designers that wish
they could have one golden
implementation of your company's design
language but instead have to contend
with many teams building their own
component sets on top of react angular
and all the other frameworks each with
annoying differences in the components
that drive your designers crazy web
components are the answer a truly write
once run everywhere component system
that still gives app teams the freedom
to choose the framework of their choice
companies like ING Electronic Arts and
the material team here at Google are
implementing their company's design
language in web components and finally
web components are also hitting a
remarkable stride inside enterprises as
a safe future-proof technology to
standardize
Google has built over 15,000 web
components internally and the number
continues to grow before a more detailed
look at why enterprises are choosing web
components we've invited our friends
from Salesforce to share some insight
into how they standardize on web
components across their developer
platform so I'll hand it over to Katie
Pitino and architect on the UI platform
at Salesforce thanks Kevin
what components and software's about
three years ago we embarked in this
journey to try to modernize our UI
platform we decided to use what
components I would like to give you some
of the details of this journey so forth
as a business is just a set of
applications they have a long list of
applications and many of these
applications actually are acquisitions
along the way and when you have an
acquisition you have a application that
is running a different stack makes it
really difficult to share different
elements UI elements through these
applications because it's just very
difficult to have the same experience on
these applications that's one of the
challenge that we have additionally we
don't only sell these applications we
sell the platform and this platform
offers the ability to create new
applications similar to those that we
offer this is another challenge because
we one components to be able to be sure
across these applications as well
additionally we offer what we call the
customization aspect of the platform
which allows you to not only customize
the applications that we offer but
customize the components inside those
applications and even create your own
components and even share them with
other developers throughout the app
exchange all these are challenges that
we were set to solve so we asked our
developers what do you want to see in a
new platform and not surprised
most of the things that they wanted are
around developer productivity they want
to be more effective at doing what they
need to do they want to use more
standards they don't want to learn the
software way of doing something they
don't want to learn the source API they
already have knowledge that they want to
reuse they also want a common component
model so if they want to customize
different
applications in our system they should
be able to use the same process they
want to be able to find people that can
help that finding and sell for
developers it's very difficult finding
out what developers this year and they
want to use the standard tools they
don't want to be forced to use
particular set of tools they will also
very passion about what they don't want
to see in our platform they don't want
to see breakage changes they want a
platform to continue to be biocompatible
they don't want you be a stuck in all
technologies they can make a change to
date in a year for now they should be
able to come back and use new technology
they don't want to be inside a wall
garden where the components that they
create and the customizations that they
do are only useful inside the cell for
cycle system they want to be able to
have components that are portable
outside of the software's ecosystem so
we looked into many of the popular
frameworks and libraries and we make a
decision to use what components but what
what what's surprising about this is
that we discover that the UI platform
happens to share the same constraints
and the same features of the web
platform itself we believe what
components are a natural fit for
software's we have no external
dependencies we're building a platform
and we also understand that different
frameworks they have different objective
for example biocompatibility was a deal
breaker for us we can now force our
developers to upgrade to a certain
version and all these popular frameworks
and libraries they all use semantic
version so you need to get everyone onto
the same version you know in order to
upgrade we cannot afford that instead
what we create is what we call the nanny
web components or lwc for troll these
are just web components is a
foundational set of components that we
use across these different apps you can
create your own on top of that since
they are what components they're
interval they are biocompatible and
future-proof we like that from what
components but what components API are
very low-level API as Kevin mentioned so
we create this thin layer around it that
we call other
see this offers a little bit of
developer activity enhancement because
you will be able to create components
faster also in this layer we actually
fill the gaps that the web components
API is have today for example
accessibility and on top of that we
offer a design system from software's
which is built-in in this layer you can
opt out if you want additionally because
these are what components we can
actually extract the structure of all
these components we know the exact API
of each of them and therefore we can use
it in our builders we can use them
metadata to provision the components and
preload them those are the things that
we really like about what components the
ability to understand the shape of it
finally software is now built on web
components we like the ability to have
this common component model that we can
use across these different applications
we like the performance of it because we
don't need to do anything the browser
does the heavy lifting
they are biocompatible forever and we
can evolve alongside the platform
encapsulation is also another goodie
that we get from the web components and
finally the ability to use those
components in different applications and
beyond the self force platform those are
the things that we really like about web
components let me get back to Kevin
thanks scaredy so as you can see with
big enterprises like Google and
Salesforce betting on web components and
with the web components API is now
natively implemented in the vast
majority of users browsers you really
can start using web components today to
solve some of the use cases that we
discussed earlier so if you're building
a web app consider one of the many web
component sets out there here are just a
couple of examples so the ionic
framework team has an enterprise-grade
set of web components that are ready to
use and there are neat sets developed
out in the community like the wired
elements these have a really cool
hand-drawn effect that are perfect for
prototyping applications and finally
there are great special-purpose web
components like model viewer develop
here at Google buy the augmented reality
team with just one HTML tag you can add
a are ready 3d content to any web page
using this web component without knowing
anything about WebGL or the new
xrap is that power this kind of
experience again just by adding an HTML
tag and finally if you're developing a
design system for your company and
needed to be consumed in a lot of
different stacks or if you're venting a
specialized component or library that
you want to be used in any environment
like we showed with model viewer or if
you need to add interactivity to HTML
based content from a CMS consider
authoring your components using web
components you can start building web
components today using the native custom
element API shipping in the browser you
just make a class that extends HTML
element and register it against an HTML
tag name with the browser's custom
elements API and the browser will
automatically create an instance of your
class and call the lifecycle callbacks
on it whenever the HTML tag is created
but since web components API is are
pretty low-level there are libraries
that can help you get started a lot more
quickly you can check out lid element a
web component base class developed here
at Google that has a great functional
rendering experience very similar to
react you define your properties and
then write a render method that returns
the components internal HTML as a
function of data so if you're a
developer coming from react and when a
similar developer experience for
creating interoperable components check
out lit element finally since web
components are no longer a niche
technology but a built-in part of the
platform many other popular libraries
also now support outputting
interoperable web components for example
angular elements is a first-class
feature of angular that lets you use
angular to build web components and
vue.js has a very similar capability and
finally there's a new class of
frameworks like stencil jeaious which
are purpose-built for building web
components and finally open WC org is a
great resource maintained by enthusiasts
in the community that's a great
collection of guides and tips and
pointers for using web components so
make sure to check out all the resources
linked in the description below thanks
for watching
[Music]